do you think modern women deserve to be
courted no one deserves nothing bro
that's what I'm saying from yeah what do
you think
I don't know I think women should be
courted all like modern women too yeah
deserve I think they should why not but
deserve though that's the that's the key
word no because because I think like if
you're not traditional how can you
expect a traditional outcome
yeah do they want to be courted
I mean I think girls like say that but
they don't typically yeah that's what
I'm saying like pick the guys that Court
them
they weren't the bad boys that's what
they want
yeah bad boys they don't do courtship do
they bad boys don't talk bad boys smash
bad boy smash first date yeah
yeah yeah yeah
we look at that bad boys take girls out
on dates
they do I think so as well one day
sometimes one day might be a cheap one
still
like what's the what's the max twenty
dollars not 50 50
okay
you think
I think that they should I think that
they should be caught in brought back
into relationships because I feel like
it would just balance everything how it
makes it if you keep doing something
it's going to become its norm and that's
why I just feel like there's masculine
women
because of the imbalance of what of the
roles what the men and women are
supposed to have I strongly believe that
men and women are completely two
different two different people do you
understand we look at things differently
we're designed differently and the
moment that we more understand that the
better that we'll get along then it's
easier to find your compatibility and
stuff like that courtship is getting to
know somebody courtship is Shane respect
to somebody courtship is showing
somebody how special you think they are
those are the type of things that women
like to have yeah so that's that's why I
look at those things that's why I think
that those things should happen so when
you say modern women I look at modern as
you mean in this day and time that we
are now of course because if you don't
do it then like our children our
daughters to come and stuff they're not
going to have any of that you kind of
have to I think it's just like wait for
the next round of 22 year olds I think I
think I think our area is done to be
honest because at the end of the day
like all what you're saying is all well
and good calm yeah but the real the
reality the reality is like okay say I
want to quote the average modern chick
walking around a typical girl walking
around she's probably talking to at
least five to ten other guys she's
probably sleeping with one or two other
guys bro like why am I gonna Court her
it's a different time that whole
courting thing in my opinion it kind of
refers to an older time like a more
traditional time where the women were
traditional the men were traditional and
it made sense to call girls because you
knew she wasn't sleeping around you knew
she didn't throw a box around bro you're
not saying whereas now bro like
once you hit 25 most girls you you're
going to encounter have thrown their box
around considerably but even if they
want to forget about the guys that
didn't do it well or they just didn't
like that much they they've done a lot
do you get what I'm saying so the
quoting thing deserve I wouldn't agree
with deserve if you if you come across a
decent woman then yeah she can get
courted but I what's the percentage of
decent women walking around that's
debatable in it what do you think it is
what a passage yeah
um ah bruh with all social media
Instagram you know cardi BC girls the
influence especially in the UK influence
of uh American
bruh oh no bruh I reckon it's like
15 15. that's yeah 15. I honestly think
that because and that's going from my
experience and the experience of the
guys that I know the things that girls
I've had entanglements with what they've
said do you know I mean like bro like
you know I I've been in situations where
I'm sleeping with a girl and then the
girl's on hinge going out on dates and
then she's coming back telling me how
the date went and I'm sleeping with her
again
that's like obviously that's good for me
like you could call me a scumbag I don't
care that's good for me but for that guy
that women paid for that he's courting
her
that's a joke to me and then from like a
guy's point of view it's just like the
it's almost like the the cast that way
the benefits because it's like you're
spending money and your time and your
attention on a girl but like what do you
get in return the average age of first
marriage in the UK is 31 so you don't
get Youth and you don't get Purity
anymore you get used to books yeah and
so it's like and you don't really get
loyalty anymore because the divorce rate
is 50 and women leave 70 to 80 percent
of the time 90 of their college educated
so it's kind of like the juice isn't
really worth the squeeze from the man's
point of view and then if she if she
divorces you she's taking the kids away
so if she's paid too she's paid to take
the kids away there you go
yeah that makes sense
there's a matting out here
so basically what you're saying is you
don't think there's hardly any decent
women out here no do you guys do you
women agree with that
I think from like 1950s standards I
would agree yeah I think that's 100 True
like women back then were virgins they
had cookbooks they were wives I don't
think most women today were raised to be
wives they weren't raised by wives how
would they know how to be one
and a lot of girls wasn't raised with
their father as well that's another
aspect in that as well again and I just
think we live in a very selfish culture
where it's me me and like when you're
traditional like you believe in the
family before me but like how many how
many women are willing to give up their
dreams for a man
how many women women are really willing
to put the family first
yeah I will agree
um with pearl there's been some things
that I've seen on TV and I just been
like man is this how
women are portraying themselves nowadays
and it's just the same type of woman and
I like think like do y'all wonder why
like you're single or you have baby
daddies or XYZ it's like do you ever
think about your actions and then um
something that Pro just said about
um women will leave men for their
careers instead of staying with them
there was this uh post that I saw there
was a woman she was with some she was
with a man that took care of her house
paid for everything and she wanted to
become an actor she left went to I think
was Atlanta and she wanted to pursue her
dream in acting got there
didn't do acting became a stripper got
pregnant and she was like maybe I should
go back to him so he can help me
while she's pregnant it's just like it
just doesn't make sense and I think of
like my grandparents generation where my
Grandma had 13 kids for my grandpa like
I I know guys that want like five six
like a lot of children and they can't
find someone that wants to do that for
them like most women only want one or
two kids because they don't like it's
like more about them and their lifestyle
rather than having as many kids as
possible like like the women back then
used to want kids they want to do it
early they wanted as many as they
possibly could because there was no
security
I think if you was um if you're from a
time where you're able to live out your
role which is like you know you stay at
home and you have your children you feel
secure within that I feel like nowadays
women are in relationships and they're
always looking they're always thinking
like it might not work out I might get
divorced but I might need a backup plan
because men ain't supplying the same
security as back in the day because
they're not staying in the homes do you
mean money or you mean I mean security
is financial and emotional as well okay
if a woman feels Totally Secure within
our mind I believe that that's when she
will feel feminine enough to give you
loads of kids a woman that feels that
she has to go out and do something for
herself is because if she's in a
relationship is because she's not being
fulfilled properly by her man simple
because if you're in a traditional
relationship the man is the provider and
the woman's the Homemaker do you
understand the problem is women won't go
down in lifestyle in order to have a
family so like
so no I I think women are more I'll give
you an example okay and I don't I don't
mean to pick on you but like you your
nails done right yeah and I noticed most
girls that come on my show have their
nails done and they they usually have
very nice clothes and it's like it's
like lifestyle
but and and so like I've asked this
question where I say would you go down
in lifestyle like you make this much
money would you go down to this
lifestyle at forty thousand thirty
thousand dollars to for a year for a
family and they say no
like because a man on one income you can
afford an apartment but women want a
house if you go down buy that much money
because children cost money
and though that's the realest that's the
reality of it so if you can't just sit
down and just you you might just say I'm
gonna just have five children like that
but back then they used to like figure
it out so like my dad my dad was one of
13 kids and they would do hand-me-downs
like they lived off of one salary it was
a fireman's salary it wasn't a ton of
money they just lived poor because it
was always about the family first but
like women don't want to do that there
ain't no women not I want to live but
like women not want to live Instagram
lifestyle bro that's why I loaded them
on Instagram bro that's why a lot of
them are on Instagram taking pictures of
the plate of food that they're eating
Ralph
come on bro come on like from the uh
what's it the music video vixen girl to
the Girl Next Door they're all doing the
same thing bro it's the same programming
so if a guy can't provide XYZ they're
not going for it bro they're just not
bro like hypergamy is on story it's like
in this in this era or even like I think
about how my mom like she got she got
like a top half a percent guy right but
she quit her job she was a teacher she
quit her job to go work for him he said
if you want to be with me like you need
to move otherwise like go find a new
boyfriend she said okay I'm gonna quit
I'm gonna come to you but like how many
women nowadays are willing to quit their
job for a man that has no money because
he had no money
she obviously could see his potential
and she allowed him to lead not believe
that you should let your man lead but
not make some idiot may lead you because
he's leading you into nowhere sometimes
do you understand what I mean that
that's what I feel like we keep talking
about the women but with me I think it
goes back on to the men women adapt do
you understand they've only they're
they're taking pictures of plates on
their own because it's been normalized
because everybody's hiding and they're
not showing PDA so women are now saying
right that's it we're just going to show
the plates do you know what I mean I've
never gone through that because I've
always been in a relationship my mum's
always been a relationship my grandma's
always been in a relationship do you
think you represent like the typical
modern woman walking out there when
people are saying that they're not
decent I definitely don't represent that
no then we should really focus on what
the majority is because that's the
majority of girls walking around you're
saying but some people can say that you
attract what you are do you understand I
believe that social media and and the
media portrays a certain type
I'm in a beauty industry and I don't
come across just people in the social
media that I see in social media on a
day-to-day basis that isn't just what is
out there I don't agree there's no
absolutes there's no absolutely you know
what I mean there's no absolutes no one
said I don't think all of most of the
women I don't think majority of the
women are just how many women have you
dated
I don't date women exactly so you don't
really know what you're talking about
all the time it doesn't matter what you
say it doesn't matter because you don't
date them so you don't know what you're
talking about I do know what I'm talking
about but you haven't done it I just
disagree with the fact that I just I
just started so you don't know what
every woman is though that's the same
that's that I'm talking yeah
you haven't been with every woman no but
I'm not saying I never said all and I
said that before I said that before I
think that's very that's my that's my um
so if okay
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible